the Biden Administration is also
wrestling with how to fight inflation a
costly reality for families all around
the world now we all know the price of
food and other items is going up what
you may not realize is the amount of
product you're getting in some cases is
going down Carter Evans has more
the next time you're shopping check
closely this live cereal box recently
got taller but it lost two and a half
ounces that's almost a bowl and a half
of cereal experts call it shrinkflation
unfortunately we're in the middle of a
tidal wave of shrinkflation because of
inflation Ed dwarski founded
consumerworld.org a consumer resource
guide that investigates trends like
shrinkflation it's a very sneaky way to
pass on a price increase but he says
companies are dealing with Rising costs
just like the rest of us they know
consumers will notice a direct price
increase but they won't notice if the
product gets a little bit smaller these
Charmin toilet paper packages look the
same but dwarski says the roles recently
got shorter by 30 sheets in 2008 Ice
Cream came in half gallon cartons then
they went down to 56 ounces and the
current size is 48. but ice cream maker
Tillamook was very open about its
decision saying in order to be
profitable they decided on the option
that would be least disruptive to their
fans and keep the price the same they
chose to cut the size by 14 percent that
means this carton used to have this much
more ice cream check out these bags of
dog food the larger bags said you were
getting three pounds free the smaller
bag says you're getting four pounds free
for the same price what gives there's no
free lunch even for your dog it went
from 50 pounds to 44. that's all you
need to know forget about all the
fanciful marketing language and it's
hard to tell one of these bottles of
dish soap has a half ounce less how do
you spot shrinkflation it's not easy to
spot at all we all have to become much
more net weight conscious that means
look at the products you buy every day
and when you go to the store see if it's
changed or not but dwarski has no
indication manufacturers are trying to
rip people off now I can imagine it's
not an easy decision for companies it's
actually a costly decision for companies
they have to retool their manufacturer
factoring plant they have to resize the
packaging but even with all those costs
manufacturers think it's worth it when
the economy gets a little bit better do
you think we'll see sizes get bigger it
tends to be a one-way Street for CBS
morning's Carter Evans Los Angeles
we reached out to makers of the products
we highlighted for comment but none of
them responded meanwhile Ed Dorsey is a
national hero as far as I can tell I'm
glad somebody is paying attention to the
shrinkage going on in some of this
packaging talking about keeping it real
that's exactly it was very specific we
appreciate that Dorsey